what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren and I
truly believe that the MCU has just
changed for good for the better I was
hoping a good change would come and it
did and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
showed me that and I really think that
this movie is about to do some things
for Marvel that they haven't seen in a
very long time now no spoilers in this
video but I can still talk about how
it's changing the MCU and what Marvel
Studios did with this movie to make it
different from the past few years let's
talk about that but first I'd like to
thank the sponsor of this video Marvel
future fight by netmarble it's the
game's homecoming event and we're so
excited for the update with an update on
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 on the
horizon in celebration of the new movie
if you haven't heard of Marvel future
fight you need to Marvel future fight is
a mobile fighting game where you can
play as the most iconic Heroes and take
on the most fearsome villains in the
Marvel Universe and the cool thing about
Marvel future fight is the ability to
customize and enhance any character
you'd like the game has expanded their
roster of 250 plus Heroes 2 and 420 plus
Uniforms over the last eight years and
the great news is there's an in-game
homecoming party on April 26th in
celebration of the eighth year
anniversary that includes 50 off
uniforms and 50 additional bonus
crystals there are even major rewards
such as a selector tier 3 hero just by
logging in there's also a Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 update that you won't
want to miss so click the link in my
description and use code eight years
party for 300 crystals just right off
the bat Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is
truly the best movie to come from Marvel
Studios in a handful of years and I
think that there is actually a pretty
good reason for this and again I am
going to talk a little bit about the
movie but not give any spoilers away
more about just kind of how the movie is
made and some things that you kind of
need to know about the movie to really
appreciate what it is you see if you're
here you love Marvel or you're at least
like Marvel and a vast majority not all
but a vast majority of people who like
and love Marvel Studios have said that
they have kind of locked quality
recently and even Marvel Studios
themselves have admitted to this but
Marvel Studios has made a lot of
structural changes recently but
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 didn't need
any changing at all and the reason for
that is that this was always a James
Gunn film no interference really from
Marvel Studios James Gunn got fired
after Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 and
what we learned from that is that James
Gunn was really upset because the
guardian's trilogy was essentially about
the story of the Guardians of course but
Rocket Raccoon and he wrote the stories
for all of the movies and he directed
them the way he wanted to direct them he
made them his movie and this is
important because we recently learned
when Marvel Studios fired executive
Victoria Alonso some things came to the
surface and people said that she said
the directors don't really direct the
movies but Marvel Studios does and their
Executives meaning they have final say
if they don't want something in a movie
or they do want something in a movie
they're gonna make that change despite
what the director wants now I don't
think she was speaking for the whole
company there at all I think that was
just her opinion now of course Marvel
Studios has power but the difference
with guardians 3 is that they let James
Gunn make his film and you can see that
here because as much as I love the
interconnectivity of the MCU and that is
there in the Guardians film I think
Marvel Studios has had a problem
recently with either trying to connect
too much or not enough I feel like
they've kind of been in the middle and
haven't really picked a lane for a lot
of their projects however Guardians does
because it's all about the Guardians
James Gunn got to finish his Trilogy and
his very specific story that he wanted
to tell and it was completely focused on
this team does it set up new things yes
does it show that yes but it is totally
and completely connected to the actual
story that we are going through and it
doesn't take away from the story at all
and the results were kind of
mind-blowing this was one of the best
films from Marvel Studios kind of just
period not just one of the best in the
past few years but it's just one of the
best films to come from Marvel it's one
of the most emotional films that come
from Marvel Studios but it is still also
at the same time hilarious it's
basically what we know the Guardians to
be it's not a big deviation from what we
already know and love with the Guardians
because James Gunn got to finish the
story that was simply focused on the
Guardians and I think that this is what
is going to change Marvel Studios they
clearly realize that the quality has
suffered they have stated that they are
going to focus more on quality and not
quantity they've made some changes
internally firing some Executives moving
some people around they are actively
trying to get better and it shows with
this movie but more importantly I think
this movie is going to kind of be a big
staple for them and they're really going
to learn from the entire process of the
making of Guardians 3 how they were
involved how they worked with the
directors and specifically with
storytelling because the results for
Guardians 3 speak for themselves let's
talk about just a few reviews first of
all here's Arnold Schwarzenegger's
review who if you did not know is the
father-in-law of Chris Pratt Chris Pratt
married his daughter I also saw him at
the premiere and fist bumped him and
fist bumped Chris Pratt it was amazing
this is what he said on Twitter I saw
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 last
night and wow Chris Pratt you crushed it
a Non-Stop perfect mix of comedy and
action I loved it and I'm very very
proud of you and I gotta say Chris Pratt
and the whole cast crushed it they
really really did this was a perfect
send-off for the Guardians of the Galaxy
however like I've been saying it's not
the end of the guardian's team in
general just this specific Guardians
team that we have now and side note I
really gotta say that whatever you think
you know is going to happen you don't
because the ending is not what I thought
it was going to be some other scenes are
not what I thought they were going to be
so just go in with an open mind ready to
see the awesome Guardians that we know
and love but let's dive into some other
reviews because after the movie I was
trying to process what had happened now
if you haven't caught my personal
spoiler free review I suggest you check
that out there is an aspect of the movie
that I really didn't like but that is
very personal to myself so after I asked
everybody around me what they thought
about the movie initial reactions right
after the movie ended I asked Greg Alba
and John Humphrey over at the real
Rejects and Greg said he loved it that
it was one of the best Marvel movies
that he's seen he definitely thought
that it was the best Guardians of the
Galaxy film in the franchise and that he
wanted to watch it again immediately I
asked Jon and he said the same thing and
we were all crying we all shed tears a
lot of parts during the movie and John
said he loved it they both really loved
it and if you haven't caught their
reviews please go check them out over at
the real rejects then I asked my good
friend Wendy and she said she loved it
as well her review is up on her YouTube
channel as well the movie couple then I
asked my friend Tessa over at Mama's
geeky she absolutely loved it she too
said it was the best film since Avengers
endgame and you can check out her review
on her website and YouTube channel but
here's where it got really odd the after
party after I went around and I kept
asking people that I knew what did you
think of the movie and I didn't hear a
single bad review at all in fact I was
the only one who really had anything
negative to say about it and that's only
because I hate half human half cyborg
robot people it freaks me out and that
was my only complaint about the movie
but literally nobody else really said
anything bad about this film and after I
was actually speaking with some people
over at Marvel and I was asking them
what they take away from this what they
take away from movies and they confirmed
to me they learn from every movie after
every single movie comes out and they
see reactions and critic reviews and
everything they get together and they
talk about what they can improve what
was the best what was the worst what
went wrong and how do they fix that for
upcoming movies and since this movie is
clearly a home run from Marvel Studios I
think they're going to take away a lot
from this as far as how it was executed
how they let James Gunn take the helm
and let him be a writer and let him be a
director of course they were supervising
and talking with them about everything
but really it was his movie as a film
Creator Marvel Studios has already done
some of this already they have gotten
new writers for new projects for
Deadpool 3 for the Fantastic Four
they've also changed directors for
projects as well they are literally
changing the stories because they don't
think that they're going to be good they
don't think the audiences are going to
like this stories so Marvel Studios I
can attest is literally doing everything
that they can to make better projects
and it just shows so hard with this
movie now like I mentioned there were
some aspects to this movie that I didn't
like and I think that's going to be the
same for a minority of the people that
go and see this but again every movie
isn't perfect for everybody so just go
in with the expectation that you're
gonna see a fun film and that you're
probably gonna get your heart strings
tugged at I know not everyone's a softy
like my friends and myself but there are
a lot of moments that hit hard and above
all it is hilarious it is a Guardians
film so you're gonna enjoy a true
Guardians of the Galaxy movie if you've
liked the other ones I think you'll like
this one a lot and I truly think that
this is going to restore a lot of faith
in the MCU for a lot of Marvel fans
which just makes me super happy this
film made me so happy because I know
that the future is going to be amazing
so go in there have some fun and we'll
do a spoiler-free talk after we'll do a
live stream and we'll talk about with
all of you what you thought about it so
I look forward to that in the meantime
please make sure to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
the latest MCU news you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign